كان هذا الصباح مأساويًا للغاية بالنسبة
لنا ،
أصاب صاروخان كروز
هاركيف المدينة التي تقع على
حدود الاتحاد الروسي ، وكان هناك
دائمًا
العديد من الروس هناك
ودائمًا ما كانوا ودودين ، وكانت
هناك علاقات دافئة هناك
أكثر من 20 جامعة
هناك.  المدينة التي تضم أكبر
عدد من الجامعات في بلدنا ، حيث
يكون الشباب ذكيًا
هناك الناس الذين تجمعوا هناك طوال
الوقت وكانوا يتجمعون هناك طوال
الوقت للاحتفال بجميع
الاحتفالات في أكبر ساحة في
بلدنا
ساحة الحرية
و
وهذه أكبر ساحة في
أوروبا وهذا صحيح يسمى
ميدان الحرية ، هل يمكنك أن تتخيل هذا
الصباح ضرب صاروخان للسجن
ميدان الحرية هذا
العشرات من
القتلى هذا هو ثمن الحرية
التي نقاتلها
فقط من أجل
أرضنا ومن أجلنا  الحرية
على الرغم من حقيقة
أن جميع مدن الحياة في بلدنا
محظورة الآن ،
فلن يدخل أحد ويتدخل
بحريتنا وبلدنا.  صدقوني في
كل
مربع اليوم بغض النظر عما
يطلق عليه ، سيتم
تسميته اليوم ساحة الحرية في كل مدينة في
بلدنا
، لن يكسرنا أحد ،
نحن أقوياء ،
نحن الأوكرانيين ،
لدينا رغبة في رؤية أطفالنا
أحياء
مسيحي كان هناك شيء
من التشبيه المجازي في كل هذا ، لقد رأيت
الزعيم الأوكراني الملتحي في قميص
في خضم حرب يتحدث إلى
الناس الذين يرتدون بدلات
رسمية في البرلمان الأوروبي ونعم
كانت هناك وحدة أوروبية رائعة
ونعم لديهم  اتخذ إجراءات اقتصادية ولكن
عندما ترى هذا التجاور ، فإنه يجعلك
تتساءل هل يكفي هل يمكن أن يكون ذلك كافيًا لإنقاذ
ذلك الرجل الملتحي من الهجوم الروسي ،
فأنت تعلم
أنه في قصره الرئاسي ولا يرتدي أي
قميص يرتدي زيًا عسكريًا
إذا تحدثنا عن القميص باللون الأخضر
للجيش ، فمن الواضح أنه سمح
للأسباب التي يفترض أنها ضرورية لتنمو لحيته ،
إنه أحد الأشخاص ،
فهذا أكثر من مجرد
رمز  يا رجل لم يعتقد أحد أنه
سيتعين عليه مواجهة هذا كما تعلم أنه
يرتقي إلى مستوى المناسبة ويظهر
أنه لن يترك شعبه في
أسوأ لحظة في التاريخ الأوروبي
منذ نهاية الحرب العالمية الثانية ، أعني أننا
لم نر  هذا النوع من الأشياء في
أوروبا منذ الأربعينيات من القرن الماضي ، ما يحدث أمرًا غير
عادي ، وكما
يفعل هذا الرئيس الشجاع في
عاصمة محاصرة وربما قريباً محاصرة ، لديك
وزير الخارجية الروسي يتحدث
إلى الأمم المتحدة بأمان شخص تعرفه أجنبيًا.
الغموض في موسكو والكذب مرة أخرى حول
من يدعوه زيلينسكي بالنازي الجديد الذي
وصف النظام هناك بمجموعة من مدمني المخدرات
والفاشيين الجدد قائلين إنه يتعين علينا
القيام بهذا
السبب
لأن أهل دونباس
الانفصاليين الروس هنا قال إنهم
بطريقة ما  عدم السماح لهم بالتحدث باللغة
الروسية
بجدية ، هذا هو مستوى
الانفصال عما يحدث الآن
أنهم يحاولون القول في موسكو
إن شعب
وحكومة أوكرانيا هم  لقد جلبوا هذا على
أنفسهم وهم يخبرون عن
تلفيقات كاملة ومطلقة للتاريخ
المليء بالظلم لكنهم يضعون أساسًا
منطقيًا الآن لماذا
يفعلون ويهدفون إلى القضاء على زيلينسكي